now you were a police officer yeah what
do you make of the argument that the
police are systemically racist
well like you i believe in the english
language
and and the power of words that mean
something i
i don't know what that means i'm not
trying to be an idiot i'm not being
stupid or silly or
coy so systemically racist meaning
there's a system
that has a systemic problem that's
racist
so what's interesting is these
allegations of systemic racism
are only emerging from cities run by
systems that are dominated
monopolistically
by by liberals so i i don't get one what
system you're talking about then they
say oh no no
it's when they when they start talking
about amorphous blobs you know they have
no point
like seoul's great at dismantling these
arguments thomas soul he's a legend at
it
where he tries to pinpoint people down
to actual specific ideas that are
refutable
you know the whole essence of science
facts and data are ideas that are
refutable if you have an idea that's not
refutable
that's maybe faith that's but it's
certainly not science or data
nobody can tell you what the system
that's racist
is when you point to it they're confused
like i say in new york it's a majority
minority police department
now again it would be absurd to suggest
there aren't isolated examples
of police misconduct brutality in some
cases you know we've had
abs you know abject criminality there's
no question
but we have systems set up for that we
have civilian complaint review boards
obviously the criminal process
administrative procedures
do you notice they never suggest any
kind of legitimate fix it's always
dismantle the police defund the police
they're systemically racist it's never
it's never real and and i think where
the biden campaign made a huge mistake
here
is obviously you know the sister soldier
moment that saved bill clinton's
campaign where he
sister soldier had this very
controversial song he came out and said
listen
it's wrong you can't talk like that this
is bad and of course the left wing went
nuts and bill clinton wound up handily
winning an election and
smoking it in the next election i'm not
defending bill clinton i'm just saying
like
it was biden's moment to come out and
say listen this has to stop
today period this is i'm unequivocal in
this
our police are generally very good
people policing cities for very little
money
we have these examples of misconduct but
the second part of law and order is
order
and order the essence of order is
processed and we have a process
if you have suggestions for fixing the
process i'm your president and i'm
willing to listen
we can repair and fix those processes
and everybody would have been on board
nobody sat there and defended what
happened to this guy in minnesota nobody
i was one of the first people on tv like
no no no no but we had a process the guy
got arrested he'll be tried
that's how this works biden didn't do
that he passed
and he made the same mistake david
dinkins did in new york i'll leave this
point with this because i lived through
this in new york city
new york city it was at that point three
to one democrats to republican you were
never going to get another republican
mayor again or so we thought
the city descended ben into total
madness madness
thousands of homicides a year i mean my
wife and i tell horror stories
your car it wasn't even a matter of
getting broken into it was only a matter
of how many times
i used to joke about they had that
device the club the steering wheel lock
and then the criminals learned how to
take the club off they would ice it with
freon spray
so then they had the club cover where
you'd put the so they couldn't cut the
steering wheel and then they told people
no no put the club cover on backwards so
they can't hammer the club that's how
bad the problem was they had like
a multi-layered club so they wouldn't
steal your car it was such an
embarrassment
like it was like when am i going to get
mugged not is it going to happen
giuliani comes in runs on a strict law
and order message i mean that's
basically i'm going to cut taxes law and
order that's his entire message
he wasn't a very socially conservative
guy at the people forget that
he comes in i've lived through this
entire thing he slides by loses the
first time
wins the second time slides by runs for
re-election everybody's like guy's got
no shot the city's almost entirely
cleaned up disney moves into times
square he wins by 18 points
in new york city how biden didn't see
this coming
i mean it was the biggest you know
warning sign
exclamation point in the middle of it
i've ever seen and he blew it he's never
had that moment and and he won't and i
think this is going to be his downfall i
mean i'm
i'm shocked that the trump campaign has
not as of yet really gone
even more aggressive on on this
particular point i mean joe biden went
and visited kenosha
and uh and while visiting kenosha he
made a phone call to jacob blake the man
who was shot by the kenosha police
jacob blake is an alleged rapist the
reason that the police were there is
because
they were called to the scene by a woman
who alleged that he digitally raped her
with her child in the room
and there was joe biden suggesting that
the officers who had to shoot him
because he was
resisting arrest and went around to the
driver's side of his car and tried to
pick a
knife up off the floorboards that they
shot him and
biden's response was to call jacob blake
with condolences an alleged rapist
and to suggest that the officers be
arrested
i don't know how that has not become the
focal point of of the trump campaign at
this point frankly
yeah you know i was doing an appearance
and i mentioned this the other day that
isn't it so bizarre that the social
fabric has just
collapsed to such a point where remember
when we were kids you played cops and
robbers and
no nobody wanted to be the robber like
that was like the kid you didn't like
the neighbor make him the robber
we don't like him you know poor guy boy
i don't want to be the robbery now it's
the opposite everybody wants to be the
robber and not the cop and you think
the damage they've done to our culture
where
they've unmoored us from any objective
values of what's good you know i read
this
this great piece in the journal forgive
me i can't remember was an op-ed about a
week ago
it was on the weekend i can't remember
the author which i hate uh should give
him a hat tip but it was such a
wonderful piece how
when you accept this idea that oh all
ideas have equal validity than none do
um because it's absurd like there's
there's there's unquestionably top of
the totem pole bad ideas that should be
absolutely categorically
disregarded like the police are
generally good law and orders a good
thing rioting is bad
but now we see this new book like in
defense of looting
i mean this is what happens and this is
how you get a society where
people want to be the robber now and not
the cop which ironically that book
one of my friends put out a tweet the
other day which was hilarious the in
defense of looting book where again all
ideas are worth hearing
uh which you and i both know are not
like socialism's not worth hearing out
um whoever tells you that's a with
no context for history at all
the in defense of looting book if you go
to the flat back of the front flap
um it has a copyright thing where you
need permission to
print this book so don't loot that book
which is right don't loot my book just
loot everybody else's book
and this is the left they've unmoored us
from any sense of objective good
and when you think about it you know the
reason why they do that is quite simple
i mean the whole essence of socialism
is a is a subjective interpretation of
at any given moment what's good or bad
for the collective
if you have a set of bedrock ideas and
big our constitutional rights
socialism can't exist because the
essence of it is to treat people
unequally right
these are the bad guys these are the
good guys the next day no no those are
the bad guys these are the good guys
take their
these are the farmers the dread though
they were good guys yesterday no they're
bad guys today steal their stuff
that's what socialism is it requires
subjectivity and the left is
the left really through their academic
institutions has dismantled any sense
right now of objective good
to the point where a guy running for
president meets with the guy accused of
this disgusting crime
and and nobody i mean ben really is is
it even a scandal no
nobody's even mentioned that facts don't
care about your feelings and it's a fact
that the ben shapiro show is the largest
conservative podcast in the nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button and
stay up to date on all of our content